step one is understanding where your
Baseline health status is at which means
measuring each of the 10 truths and
there will be guidance on how to do that
once you've measured them you can put
them into our calculator which then
gives you your longevity score now
you're ready to start the challenge
there's references to support all of the
interventions that we're recommending
across the 12 weeks and you'll be
getting emails along the way as I said
which will be
with coaching uh and providing key
learnings and at the end of the 12 weeks
uh you'll go back to that landing page
you know having re retested everything
put all your information back into the
calculator and you can see how that
longevity score has changed